تاملوا من الله انه احنا نرجع لغزه ولو
انه مالناش بيت ولا انه مالناش اي حاجه في
المنطقه اللي احنا عايشين فيها لكن بدنا
نرجع على السجاعيه ونعمل خيمه زي هذه ونضل
عايشين ايش جنب ركام البيت اللي احنا
فقدناه لانه احنا يعني الواحد كله عن عنده
انتماء لاهله عنده انتماء لبيته انتماء
لوطنه فاحنا ظروفنا سيئه جدا نتامل انه
نرجع الى البيت ولو كان مهدم ولو كان كل
شيء بنعمل خيمه برضه جنب البيت المهدم
بتمنى في عام
2024 حياه تكها حياه تكون انتهى الحرب
انتهت وندخل حياه سعيده حتى نعيش باقي
عمرنا صحيح انها غزه ادمرت ما في مسكن
نسكن لكن اقل ما فيها نبطل نسمع صوت
الطياره والزنانه نبطل هالاطفال يخافوا
نلتم احنا وحبايبنا اللي ضايل بس هي اللي
بنتمنى نعيش حياه سعيده زي اي دوله الشباب
تبعونا كلهم هاجروا بسبب الفقر قله المال
قله الشغل بالحرب اطفالنا بس اسالهم
السؤال بقول لك بدنا نعيش حياه هدوء مش قص
وحرب وطخ وشهدا واطفال ب تموت مالهاش ذنب
السلام ختام يا
اخوتكم على خير ان شاء
الله